At this month's end I
will select a few of you
to work on my spring collection.
Believe in your own vision.
Push through self-doubt.
I will not hesitate
to let you go.
I just want it to be perfect.
I know you've been
stressed lately,
but I'm worried about you, Anne.
I'm dealing with it.
You can tell me anything.
Don't!
Did something happen?
This is going to sound
crazy,
but have you ever seen anything
like this before?
No.
We have a new
guest with us today.
You're here because we
all have the same problem.
Some form of illness.
Like a parasite.
Are you OK?
Don't touch me.
Welcome to the club.
Honestly it was the best thing
that ever happened to me.
It's vile but everything
it tells you...
...it’s true.
I'll protect you.
It can't be real.
She's hiding
something down there.
You can't get rid of me.
Mm, so delicious.